- [David] For 24 years,
I was an investigator
for the IRS and the FBI.
I started off working bank robbery cases.
I ended up in Chicago and worked
political corruption cases.
And after I retired,
I started investigating
lost apple varieties.
In the late 1800s, apples
were extremely important
to early settlers in Washington.
They grew a variety of apples.
Most of those people decided
that farming was too hard
but all over eastern Washington,
those old orchards survived to this day.
Sometimes, I'll just drive country roads
and I'll look out and I can
recognize an apple tree from,
you know, a couple hundred yards away.
I wonder what's planted there.
It's very possible it could be
one of these lost varieties of apple
just waiting to be found.
I draw on my experience as an investigator
mainly through the use of records.
I'm searching for clues of
where these lost varieties grew.
I look at plat maps, I
look through museum records
and things like that.
Then I go out just like
in law enforcement,
I'm looking for physical evidence.
And I've got to take a
look at those apples.
I make a map and record
the GPS coordinates.
I bag them up and I mail them off
to apple identification experts.
I'm collecting these apples
from the only known Dickinson apple tree
in the United States.
These apples are absolutely
delicious off the tree.
There's only about 10 of us now
that have ever tasted the
Dickinson in the last 100 years.
I began searching for lost apple varieties
probably about eight, nine years ago.
Something like that.
People often ask me why do
you look for these apples?
And I tell them that I have been concerned
that if I don't look for
them, no one else will,
and these varieties could be lost forever.
So far, I found three
lost varieties of apples.
Those varieties include the Nero
and then the Arkansas
Beauty and the Dickinson.
So we're down to about 20 varieties
that we're looking for right now
and it's just a matter of
time hopefully to find those.